maréchal ferrant c'est quelqu'un qui
fait l'entretien des pieds des chevaux
régulièrement à l'essai semaine n'a pas
souhaité le pic du cheval est en santé
prada qui d'ipad qui épate chabal
[Musique]
à savoir pour faire des chevaux j'ai
commencé à l'âge de 15 ans à temps
partiel à 16 ans j'ai quitté l'école
parce que j'avais une business qui
m'attendait j'ai acheté mon premier
choix j'avais 15 ans puis j'ai appelé
forgeron instant à l'heure qui vient de
le faire et puis ça n'a coûté assez cher
je me suis dit si est capable je devrais
capable je l'installé sytral de course
puis j'ai suivi une formation sur
l'étape de course qui a duré trois ans
de puissants alors au phare du four à
plein temps
quel point c'est essentiel dans la vie
des chevaux premièrement on allait faire
les fous autour des chevaux pour garder
un sabot en santé protégés sont
symboliques pour performer mieux les
andes
c'était important pour des chevaux de
compétition d'être léger suggère n'a pas
mal des huitièmes
surtout faut pas que ça se touche sa
frappe
c'est très important de le faire pour
soi en live
on essaie le plus possible de garder
puis à sa peau
[Musique]
tu es très physique très demandant pour
moi dans mon jeune temps j'ai fait des
radios en plus ça l'affectait pendant
mon corps puis aujourd'hui je me
concentre juste mon fait rage fait car
j'ai fait dix quinze jours mais j'ai mon
cas top
la relation avec les gens qu'ils
rencontrent je dirais c'est comme une
famille
parce qu'on se voit ttc semaine des fois
plus ouverts s'il ya des chevaux que par
départ je dois des radios pratiquement
toutes les fins de semaine les encourage
dans leur shilov jeux sont à coke
quelque chose arrive par d'un forgeron
après 33 ans connaît pas tout fait que
des fois je trouve un projet un problème
je vois aller fouiller je vois aller
comme contactez-les d'été génère on
discute avec lave et événement qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour améliorer le
cheval puis on arrive à des bons
résultats comme ça
qu'est ce que j'aime le plus âgé pour
attirer le chaland
un cheval qu'il ya un gros problème
puis d'essayer de ramener le choix les
boiteries un cheval qui n'a vécu l'ère
inventif fourbe et pas c'est d'essayer
de mettre le cheval le plus confortable
possible qui soit c'est un challenge
pour moi c'est un défi j'aime soja riz
chinois
j'ai sauvé saab
[Musique]